Disney has been churning out family
favorite films for the better part of a
century now so there are a ton of great
animated and live-action films to choose
from in their collection it's becoming
increasingly difficult to pin down which
of their movies stand out as the most
important of all but here are our picks
for the 15 best disney movies not
including those blockbuster Marvel and
Star Wars adventures of course up what
makes this movie such an instant classic
is the charming partnership between its
main characters a young boy scout in a
stodgy old man who retrofits his house
to float up up and away to fulfill his
long denied dream of getting away from
it all with his late wife warm and
filled with colorful imagery and one gut
punch of emotional payoff up stands out
as an unforgettable animated adventure
and you'll never see helium balloons or
golden retrievers quite the same way my
name is Doug I have just met you and I
love you Wally the central characters in
wall-e may not say much but the movie
remains a showcase of what can happen
when top-notch animation meets unbridled
creativity part dystopian disaster and
part love story the film offers a
devastating look at the future of
mankind and earth if our wasteful ways
continue unchecked
Wally's cute robots only want to make
the world a better place though so
audiences are invited to remain
optimistic about the future without them
verbally telling us why Beauty and the
Beast the story of Belle Disney's most
academically inclined princess Beauty
and the Beast has claimed the hearts of
millions for good reason at its core
it's about a girl who decides not to
judge a book by its cover and finds her
own happy ending sure it's less than
ideal that she was imprisoned by the
Beast before falling in love with him
but the beauty of this Animated Classics
of visual dynamism overcomes those flaws
to make this movie a complete triumph
and the recent live-action adaptation
was almost as compelling as the original
frozen a celebration of both songs and
princesses frozen offers not one but two
imitable young ladies princesses Anna
and Elsa to fill the must have costume
racks while transforming Hans Christian
Andersen's The Snow Queen into something
far less dreary and much more whimsical
it's also stunning
beautiful with an icy landscape serving
as an elegant background to the thawing
sisterly relationship parents might be
more than ready to let the film
soundtrack go already but it's earworm
quality is just a small part of what
makes this a must watch for kids The
Incredibles the action-adventure flick
might have preceded Marvel's decade of
big-screen superhero domination but it
still holds up as a delightful reminder
of what makes costumed adventure stories
so fun to watch in the first place of
course The Incredibles is far more
cartoonish than anything in the MCU but
it takes full advantage of the quirky
possibilities of an animated superhero
movie with characters that boast a broad
range of abilities and it takes viewers
on a heartfelt family journey along the
way Cinderella Cinderella has become a
cornerstone of the Disney Catalog since
it's her castle that makes up Disney's
logo in all modern audiences might take
issue with the notion that Cinderella
only becomes the object of her Prince's
affection after getting a magical
makeover but Cinderella staying power is
this undeniable as a determination to
escape the clutches of Ramin steppe
monsters
inside out this Disney Pixar adventure
takes a clever look at the way the human
mind works animating the emotions and
impulses fighting for control of its
main character while trying to protect
the core memories making up the basis of
her personality oh sure we'll eat our
dinner right after you eat
in the story our young heroine Riley has
to adjust to a new life as her family
relocates to another city and that shift
is the spark that sensor from the
happy-go-lucky child she once was into
the rebellious tween phase a change that
happens to most people at some point
anyway so it feels very familiar and
authentically adolescent rather than
rely upon constructs of fiction like
most cartoons inside-out borrows from
reality to offer some heavy truths in an
amusing animated package Mary Poppins
author P L Travers was infamously
unhappy with Disney's adaptation of her
story but Mary Poppins arrived in
theaters as an instant musical evergreen
we can thank the movie's depiction of
its eponymous magical nanny for
memorable songs like a spoonful of sugar
and for raising the musical and visual
bar on the genre as a whole Aladdin
Disney really did take audiences to a
whole new world with this animated hit
Aladdin centered on the rags to riches
story of a street rat who stumbles upon
a magic lamp containing a ten thousand
year old genie who was all too happy to
join him on his magic carpet ride the
stunning scenery music and all the other
memorable characters are all beyond
reproach
but it's Robin Williams genie that
really elevates the picture to hilarious
new heights Peter Pan if there's one
thing we learned from Peter Pan it's to
never surrender that sense of youth and
Wonder and of course to never smile at a
crocodile there have been many terrible
attempts to recreate the magic of Peter
Pan and it's never Neverland but nothing
has come close to touching the simple
sophistication of the first version
which thrusts its sleepy little heroes
into a living dream that played with the
elements of fantasy like mermaids
fairies and sniveling old pirates the
film is fun plain and simple and mostly
stands the test of time because like its
title it never gets old Alice in
Wonderland the animated adaptation of
Lewis Carroll's story is a visual
extravaganza that plays well to children
and adults alike the movie follows its
title character down the rabbit hole
into a dreamlike and at times
nightmarish land of otherworldly
creatures that challenge her wits and
resolve the eerie landscapes were bested
only by its cast of memorable characters
movie is the definition of trippy and
still stands above the studios
live-action remake Finding Nemo finding
dory might have been more commercially
successful than its predecessor but
Finding Nemo set the tone for its
successful sequel in virtually every way
the film followed a clownfish named
Marlin and a forgetful blue tang named
Dory on their exhausting adventure to
find Marlins Lhasa and Nemo with an
actual ocean of obstacles while finding
Dory certainly touched on all the
successful elements of the first film
namely tracking down a missing fish
who's been scooped from the sea with the
help of some adorable Finny friends the
soul of the first adventure was so much
stronger Lady and the [ __ ] even
thinking about the spaghetti scene and
lady in the trap is bound to induce
feelings of both hunger and romance this
story of a proper society food shoe
accidentally lands herself in the
company of strays is a pure delight and
while Disney's 101 Dalmatians also had a
full-on litter of doggies to love
there's simply no film for a baby quite
as graceful as miss lady ma'am whose
friends are also as human as any
two-legged type could hope to be Toy
Story 3 this may have been the third
outing for woody buzz and the rest of
the gang but Toy Story 3 out shown the
previous two installments in the way of
emotional impact the film picks up with
Andy heading off to college we're having
a cowboy and space stall won't earn him
any cool points in his dorm the toys are
packed up for the Attic but are
accidentally sent to a daycare filled
with reckless children and a Bowie bear
together they have to fight their way
back to where they belong wherever that
might be now that Andy's no longer a kid
their journey offers an emotional
parable about the process of abandoning
childish things and really resonates
with audiences particularly adults who
might have been surprised to find
themselves bawling over the lost toys
that symbolized so many bittersweet
bygones The Lion King this family
favorite really does offer the full
circle of Disney's animated strengths
the film is rich with stunning
landscapes and teeming with character
variety and morals on top of all that
there are deeply identifiable sets of
emotion at play for kids it's easy to
understand Simba's joy desperation for
freedom and a sense of being lost
without his family framework for parents
protecting your kids at all costs
becomes the most base instinct of all so
everything about this movie story rings
true let an old pro show us done add in
one outstanding soundtrack and it's no
wonder the Lion King still reigns
supreme